[Music]
okay
where to start
[Music]
my name it's ethan ethan winners
it's been three years since everything
happened at the baker house
i was looking for my wife who
disappeared
i got an email from her
she told me to come get her and of
course that's how i ended up in the
middle of nowhere louisiana
i found mia being held captive in a dark
basement
she wasn't thinking right
she attacked me like some kind of wild
animal
later on i found out that she was
infected by a special kind of mold
i looked all over the house trying to
find an antidote a vaccine
anything
the people who lived there were already
infected
what was left of them wasn't human
the source of the infection was a
bioweapon that looked like a little girl
her name was evelyn
i fought the [ __ ] up family and was
able to treat me as symptoms
then chris redfield and his soldier
buddy showed up and saved the both of us
is that enough
i really don't want to talk about what
happened anymore
it's all over now
winters welcome